bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 11 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités mais aussi des
journalistes de la rédaction on commence
par les titres de cette édition des
médiateurs sur les lignes n ai eu du
réseau transilien une initiative pour
prévenir les incivilités et instaurer un
dialogue avec les usagers un contrat
entre le stif et la sncf permet à deux
équipes de médiateurs d'arpenter
désormais les trains du lundi au
vendredi et ce week end débute la 20e
édition de la semaine de l'emploi sur
saint quentin en yvelines forum de
l'emploi zoomer qui est journée portes
ouvertes
nous reviendrons sur ces événements avec
celles ayant franchi signol responsable
emplois à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et christophe dos
santos responsable de la communication
des jeunes pour l'ifa de leur joie de
montigny le bretonneux et philippe
l'étrange entraîneur des handballeuses
de montigny le bretonneux a quitté son
poste en plein milieu de la saison
il sera en plateau aux côtés de michael
elle me d'euros pour nous expliquer les
raisons de son départ
et vous avez peut-être remarqué leur
présence depuis hier une équipe de
tournage a investi le parc des sources
de la bièvre et la bibliothèque de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines
depuis hier c'est donc le décor d'une
nouvelle série policière réalisé par
alfred lot cet épisode pilote de la
série policière intitulée emma sera
diffusé sur tf1
stéphane amphoux directeur de production
nous en dit plus il est est au micro de
camille lambert ses pilotes de deux
épisodes d'une série qui va s'appeler
emma olaya la scène d'un noyer
enfin un jeune qui est censé s'être noyé
et puis toutes les enquêtes autour à la
découverte du corps
et puis après en attendant la
bibliothèque et une autre scène car les
rênes à voir ce sens et se passer dans
une fac de médecine
c'est moderne donc l'architecturé le
design nous intéresse
et puis il ya la nature autour donc
voilà c'est un compléter tout ce qu'on
cherchait en fait on cherchait une fac
avec 1 avec un point d'eau et on a
trouvé celle là et si ce milieu vous
intéresse et que vous êtes l'heureux
propriétaire d'un chien cette
information peut peut-être vous
intéresser dans le cadre d'un tournage
pour une sortie de résidence de l'auteur
emmanuel pireyre le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines recherche un
chien mais pas n'importe lequel un chiot
caniche blanc ou un bichon blanc pour
faire de la figuration
le tournage aura lieu le mardi 16
février dans le quartier de la source de
riz à montigny le bretonneux pour plus
d'infos le numéro s'affiche en bas de
votre écran et transport à présent les
médiateurs font leur entrée sur les
lignes n ai eu du réseau transilien
leur objectif anticiper les incivilités
par le dialogue ses équipes de médiation
déjà présente sur de nombreuses lignes
du réseau sont maintenant active sur ces
lignes depuis le 1er février 2016 initié
dans le cadre d'un nouveau contrat entre
le stif et la sncf
deux équipes de médiateurs sont sur le
terrain ou plutôt dans les trains du
lundi au vendredi williams elle pour ce
reportage
politesse et dialogue
voilà les fondements du métier de
médiateur depuis le 1er février deux
équipes ont fait leur apparition sur les
lignes e n ai eu du réseau transilien
leur mission anticipez les incivilités
peu plus sur la ligne est nu c'est beau
coup de pied banquette dans les trains
et beaucoup de ce câble aussi à
l'intérieur des gares du lundi au
vendredi dès 13 heures jean michel et
son équipe arpente l'intérieur des
trains mais aussi les quais et les gars
cigarettes mendicité ou traversée des
voies
autant de problèmes auxquels les
médiateurs doivent faire face toujours
avec diplomatie
la 11 mais généralement à chaque porte
pour éviter les blocages de porte pas si
les gens quand ils arrivent en masse ils
ont tendance à vouloir bloquer des
portes pour pouvoir rentrer quand même
aimé en retard de la ligue le sourire et
d'un meilleure arme des médiateurs lors
de leur intervention
ici une dame tente de faire passer avec
elle une personne sans ticket opa ratera
plusieurs agents
en prévention et l'humanisation les
médiateurs ne donne pas d'amande mais
répertorie chacune des interventions
constater les remettent aux personnes ce
coupon qui répertorie la liste des
incivilités nous donne aussi aux usagers
une frappe que l'on constate qu'il ya eu
un délit on m'expliquer de quoi il
s'agit le but de notre intervention
également et une fois on est loin sur la
grille par rapport à nos sensibilisation
s'y trouvent correct notre
sensibilisation est aussi était au coin
des montants qui risque en cas de
verbalisation par les agences ces fonds
vont mieux sensibiliser les gens à les
prévenir que de leur donner des amants
ils savent même pas pourquoi des poisons
des amendes des agents qui font partie
de l'association tisse le lien avec
laquelle travaille la sncf
au delà de la prévention ses équipes
apportent un lien social avec les
usagers par leur présence et leur
visibilité d'ici le mois de juin la
ligne c du rer accueillera de nouveau
médiateur pour une couverture complète
du réseau transilien et nous allons à
présent parler d'emploi la semaine
prochaine saint quentin en yvelines
organise la 20e édition de la semaine à
l'emploi qui se tiendra donc du 12 au 19
février pour nous en parler en plateau à
mes côtés céline la franchise signol
bonsoir le soin vous êtes responsable
emploi innovation recherche et
enseignement supérieur à saint quentin
en yvelines ainsi que christophe dos
santos vous êtes responsable de la
communication des jeunes à l'ifa de
l'eau rozoy alors au sein de cette
semaine beaucoup d'événements sont
organisés il ya des forums de
recrutement des job dating des journées
des zooms métier c'est une lan franchi
qu'elles sont un peu les
non vraiment à ne pas manquer alors tous
peuvent intéresser puisque les dés de la
semaine c'est de s'adresser à tout le
monde et de pouvoir toucher tous les
publics
mais on peut peut-être cité notamment
l'événement forum des formations métiers
qui introduit chaque année 7 cette
édition qui aujourd'hui recentré sur une
journée avant ça se déroulera sur deux
jours avec un premier temps dédié
uniquement aux collèges et lycées et une
deuxième partie à partir de 17h30 dédié
au grand public puisque l'idée c'est que
les jeunes puissent venir avec leurs
familles rencontrent et 38 centres de
formation dont il est fait de le revoir
et puis après il ya des événements aussi
dédié vous l'avais dit au recrutement en
eux mêmes avec un job dating organisé
avec pôle emploi la qui est dédié aux
demandeurs d'emploi mais un gros travail
en amont pour organiser des rencontres
sur mesure et surtout le forum de
recrutement qui se tient le 10 8 après
midi qu'ils adressent à la cible ventes
marketing commerce et où on a une bonne
vanne entreprises représentait 22
entreprises et surtout 250 offres
d'emploi sur un peu toutes les
thématiques du bac au bac +5 et ça va du
chargé de clientèle jusqu'aux
responsables des clips et enfin aussi on
veut donner une perspective d'avenir
parce qu'on travaille pas mal aussi sur
l'évolution des métiers avec notamment
un zoom métier qui sera dédié aux
métiers du futur
le voilà alors il ya également à des
journées portes ouvertes vous disiez
vous l'organiser donc justement à l'ifa
de rozoy christophe de santos donc ce
samedi
donc c'est une semaine aussi voilà qui
s'adresse justement aux jeunes avec
votre participation
tout à fait notre école il fait de leur
voix propose donc dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'emploi de pouvoir
accueillir des jeunes dans notre école
on leur montrait la possibilité de faire
des parcours en alternance de bac à bac
+5 dans notre école et à partir de là de
pouvoir trouver une insertion
professionnelle
c'est la possibilité pour eux donc de
pouvoir se former directement
d'entreprise part avec un contrat en
alternance
et puis après derrière de pouvoir
intégrer un emploi on a un taux
d'insertion professionnelle à six mois
après la fin des formations de 78%
donc voilà notre participation elle est
surtout dans ce domaine ensuite nous ça
va être l'occasion aussi pour ces jpo de
présenter l'ensemble de nos formations
nous trois filières de formation en
génie informatique et en en réseau et
génie informatique en électronique et en
robotique en domotique et en
électrotechnique et montrer les métiers
l'ensemble des métiers auxquels on peut
former il ya beaucoup d'événements
dédiés aux jeunes c'était vraiment une
volonté de les impliquer dans cette
semaine de l'emploi parce que peut-être
sur saint quentin en yvelines
il ya des choses qui sont constatées par
rapport à l'emploi des jeunes
tout à fait c'est vraiment une forte
demande pour les entreprises d'attirer
les jeunes les jeunes diplômés ou avec
une première expérience et puis
l'objectif de cette semaine c'est
d'aller de la sensibilisation jusqu'au
recrutement
donc effectivement les jeunes sont une
cible prioritaire il ya pas mal
d'acteurs qui les accompagnent sur le
territoire il ya d'autres événements qui
leur sont dédiées spécifiquement alors
c'est un événement qui organise en
partenariat avec pôle emploi et où vous
faites également participé des acteurs
économiques locaux vraiment il ya des
acteurs locales dans cette voie là bas
une journée qui est programmée avec les
partenaires de l'emploi donc ses coûts
construire avec eux on décide ensemble
du programme de ce qu'il faut ce qui est
l'idée étant d'avoir toute la palette
est effectivement on a eu des
partenariats forts notamment avec pôle
emploi ou les quatre antennes qui a sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines guyancourt rattrape avec
plaisir sa championnat 2-1 guyancourt se
sont associés pour travailler sur le job
dating est aussi toutes les communes qui
font le relais et toutes les
associations qui travaillent sur
l'emploi donc c'est vraiment une
mobilisation
général à un moment de l'année mais même
si à d'autres événements après qui se
retrouve alors au long de l'année
auparavant il ya des ateliers de
préparation justement à cette semaine de
l'emploi on est une femme en atelier ces
vidéos sur lesquelles nous avions fait
justement un reportage un petit peu
accès donc sur les nouvelles
technologies justement à l'ifa douleur
est un peu spécialiste de ces nouvelles
technologies l'électronique la robotique
ce sont des secteurs qui recrutent à 50
ans des films parce que vous êtes
également 13 en lien avec les acteurs
locaux les entreprises locales tout à
fait l'ensemble des formations que nous
faisons sont donc en alternance
elles sont financés par la taxe
professionnelle qui est versée par les
entreprises financées aussi par le la
région ile de france et donc nos
partenaires ce sont vraiment les
entreprises c'est le la mission de la
chambre de commerce une des missions de
la chambre de commerce et de répondre
aux besoins des entreprises donc nous
proposons fait des formations qui sont
créés en partenariat avec eux et donc
essentiellement des entreprises du
bassin de saint quentin et dans ces
entreprises il ya donc en effet beaucoup
d'entreprises qui travaillent sur la
robotique aujourd'hui ou sur
l'électronique embarquée sur
l'informatique les réseaux la création
de bases de données pour desservir des
sites web ou des applications mobiles
pour les smartphones qui sont
aujourd'hui donc les métiers pour
lesquels il ya une forte demande et sur
lesquels on essaie de répondre en termes
de formation vous dire également que
c'est un des secteurs qui recrutent le
plus justement sur le bassin 50 euros
tout à fait c'est un secteur qui est
commun à pas mal de filières qui sont
présentes sur le territoire puisque on a
une forte représentativité de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile du
numérique bien entendu et ça se croisent
avec notamment les besoins qu'on
évoquait sur les jeunes diplômés ou les
premières
ce expérience par rapport aux formes de
recrutement dont justement achats et
marketing
c'est aussi lié à une demande justement
des entreprises vous êtes peut-être
c'est pas un petit sondage par rapport à
ça tout à fait pour décider de cette
thématique puisque l'idée de cibler ces
forums puisqu'on voit que les forums
généralistes s'essouffle parfois et donc
il faut mieux avoir une thématique et
donc c'est un sujet qu'on a fait émerger
avec les partenaires de l'emploi avec
quelques entreprises et qui avait le
mérite d'être transversale aussi à tous
les secteurs puisque la vente le
commerce marketing c'est aussi le nerf
de la guerre pour pouvoir après
développer ou mettre en avant ce qu'on a
développés privilégier un peu la
rencontre justement ça demande des
efforts aux entreprises qui déplace un
groupe
voilà de rh passions humaines pour
rencontrer c'est un effort qu'elles font
pour pour l comment ils appréhendent un
petit peu justement cette semaine de
l'emploi
alors ça des plans déjà de la taille des
entreprises et des services qu'ils ont
c'est quelque chose qu'ils nous
demandent ce qu'on s'était posé la
question de faire peut-être évoluer les
formats des forums de recrutement donc
on a testé des choses aussi au niveau
des forums virtuels mais il ya encore
une demande pour être présent et
rencontrer les demandeurs d'emploi ou
les potentiels salariés qui veulent
évoluer et aussi on a des solutions pour
alors il ya quelques pme qui seront
présentes sur le forum du recrutement
mais il y en a d'autres qui seront
représentés aussi par un dispostif qu'on
a sur le territoire qui est la
plateforme rh qui est un outil développé
avec la région et qui permet qui apporte
du conseil des entreprises de moins de
50 salariés à la fois dans la gestion
des ressources humaines à proprement
parler mais au surtout dans le
recrutement est donc la personne
représentera des entreprises qui ne
pouvaient pas se libérer toute une
après-midi parce qu'effectivement pour
une pme c'est du temps est-ce qu'il ya
peut-être d'autres secteurs en devenir
ou en pleine croissance justement sur le
patient 50 ans divine qui avons
peut-être un peu émerger ou va y avoir
des postes proposés justement lors de
cette semaine de l'emploi lors de la
semaine de l'emploi ben on va rebondir
je pense sur les zooms métiers de
l'industrie puisque déjà très
prochainement il y aura la semaine de
l'industrie et un forum de l'alternance
suite à ce fameux l'industrie donc
autour de l'industrie de l'évolution des
acteurs et de la transition numérique il
ya plein de choses à faire et donc on
réfléchit après prague et plusieurs
événements sur le sujet est ce que le
le billion de la 19ème édition dernière
s'était plutôt bien passé vous attendez
plus de monde plus de joie que vous avez
quelques chiffres à nous communique
énormément sur les peut-être sur les
postes proposés les entreprises
présentes alors sur les places peuvent
proposer sur forum de recrutement on
aura 250 offres proposées 22 entreprises
présent plus elle représentée par la
plateforme sur l'événement aussi porté
plus dédié aux jeunes par la mission
locale
on n'a plus de sens les entreprises
présentes sur le job dating
on a pas mal d'offres aussi et surtout
pas mal de demandeurs d'emploi qui
pourront rencontrer les entreprises donc
cette année ça a bien fonctionné on
essaie contourna une forteresse forte
sélectivité côté entreprises donc
j'invite les demandeurs d'emploi ou ceux
qui veulent changer d'emploi à venir
nombreux parce que il y aura du monde à
rencontrer christophe de santos est ce
que justement vous allez peut-être
encourager vos élèves à venir à cette
semaine à l'emploi pour trouver une
atteinte parce que c'est aussi un
problème compliqué pour les élèves qui
sont en alternance trouver une
entreprise ou une entreprise c'est pas
quelque chose de simple nous on
accompagne beaucoup nos étudiants
puisqu'on a déchargé de relations
entreprises qui seul met en contact les
jeunes avec les entreprises qui récupère
les offres d'emploi et qui propose donc
des cv aux entreprises donc c'est un
match ils ont fait aussi des forums en
interne avec des grandes entreprises
comme renault orange etc qui se déplace
chez nous on se déplace chez eux et donc
oui en effet ça va être l'occasion pour
les jeunes de l'ifa de pouvoir
rencontrer des entreprises aussi faire
de voilà et puis aussi pour nous en tant
qu'école c'est vraiment un moment très
très fort
une dernière question avant de terminer
cet entretien tu conseilles rêve où je
sais pas où de petits conseils
ajustement des personnes qui
souhaiteraient venir ce sera en tout cas
cette semaine pour l'emploi voilà pourra
proposer leurs cv est ce qu'il ya des
choix des petits traits ou des pizzas
stu ceux qui ont consacré justement
belge a de se montrer intéressés de pose
et de visiter à poser des questions aux
entreprises parce qu'elle aime voir
qu'on s'intéresse à elle qu'on comprend
qu'on cherche à comprendre leur métier
voilà et j'espère qu'elles ont participé
eux aussi aux ateliers de préparation
voilà et à destination peut-être des
plus jeunes les personnes qui cherchent
à voir les jeunes qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail il faut se montrer en
effet très intéressé par ce que fait
l'entreprise prendre le temps de la
coupe de devenir avant quand même de
s'être interrogé sur ce que le métier
l'entreprise qu'ils font aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont le peut-être les les
nouveaux projets qui sont en cours
et puis essayer de voir ce qu'on peut
apporter cette entreprise quelle est la
compétence du club très bien bien merci
à vous deux vous voulez retrouver toutes
les informations donc sur les phases
heureux de passer sur le site internet
www.ifaw.org point fr et sur la semaine
de l'emploi est également un site
internet celui de saint quentin en
yvelines qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran merci à vous deux pour votre
participation
et à présent tout autre sujet un
témoignage fort celui de famille au
clame qu'il a fui la guerre du vietnam
à 36 ans aujourd'hui il en a 72 et vit
en france avec sa femme il a écrit un
livre autobiographique dans lequel il
revient entre autres sur sa période de
détention en candide rééducation
aujourd'hui il est venu livrer un
témoignage poignant aux élèves de
première du lycée descartes de montigny
le bretonneux fanny bourdillon a suivi
l'une de ses interventions regarder
comprendre la guerre du vietnam et ses
enjeux un exercice parfois abstrait pour
les lycéens au lycée descartes de
montigny l'auteur vietnamien phan quoc
nam est venu porter un témoignage rare
ne sont passés au vietnam
il en a écrit un livre les deux pères
inconnus j'ai toujours voulu écrire un
livre sur l'histoire du vietnam que j'ai
vécu moi-même c'est à dire aussi dans
les années 60 50 60 et 70 le 24 juin
1975 la nar entre en camp de
concentration
il a alors 31 ans et avec sa femme comme
millan ils ont de jeunes enfants une
détention de quatre mois qui restera en
traumatisme toute sa vie j'y allais
comme des centaines de milliers d'autres
officiers et de l'armée du sud et aux
fonctionnaires de l'armée du sud en
pensant que on va être rééduqués pour un
temps déterminé pour moi ces dix jours
mais bon moi j'ai passé 128 jours et
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que ça
va être chaud c'est rien comparé aux à
ceux qui sont restés une année deux
années cinq années les plus longs c'est
dès cette année dans ces conneries dit
que ce sans être jugé à aller dans ce
camp en pensant le steria
dijoux sur des questions sur sa période
un camp de rééducation les lycéens ont
beaucoup et pour l'âne c'est l'occasion
de transmettre ses souvenirs de la
guerre et de son exode vers la france
c'est toujours intéressant ce genre
d'intervention c'est des choses qu'on
appelle enfin l'habitude de voir ces
dynamiques puisque on a vraiment des
gens qui ont vécu qui ont vécu les
choses qui nous raconte sais pas
raconter via un professeur donc c'est on
sent un petit peu l'intensité de la
chose c'est un gros témoignages là on a
témoignage d'une personne qu'il a vécu
donc on a son ressenti on a vraiment
tout ce dont à tout ce qu'on connaissait
pas et donc c'est vraiment très
intéressant et très instructif
cette année la guerre du vietnam est au
programme d'histoire de ces lycéens plus
que les cours c'est sûrement le
témoignage de l'année de sa femme qu'ils
retiendront autobiographique vous
intéresse vous pouvez rencontrer
l'auteur demain soir au club le village
de montigny le bretonneux à 19h30
l'amicale des vietnamiens organise une
présentation de son livre et la soirée
sera suivie d'un buffet de spécialités
franco vietnamienne et tout autre sujet
à présent il vous a peut-être manqué le
bibliobus des médiathèques de 50 ans une
vigne était en panne mais il vient de
reprendre la route depuis maintenant
trois semaines
la bibliothèque mobile du réseau des
médiathèques de l'agglomération arpente
les routes pour desservir montigny le
bretonneux elancourt magny les hameaux
mais aussi la ville de trappes qui
s'ajoute à la liste de ses destinations
williams elle est allée faire un tour du
côté du biome bibliobus tarn ont regardé
ce n'est pas le marchand de glaces mais
bien le bibliobus qui a repris du
service
la médiathèque mobile qui se déplace de
ville en ville marque maintenant un
arrêt dans la commune de trappes là ont
débuté c'est une tournée tout public
donc il y a
il ya des gens du quartier ils prennent
ça comme un service de proximité de
qualité voilà les liens sont sont
différents forcément on est dans un
espace quand même assez 3 au bout d'un
moment il ya beaucoup plus de liens qui
ce qui se crée pour se faire prêter un
livre une carte d'adhérent au réseau de
médiathèques est nécessaire cd livres
sont disponibles dans cette bibliothèque
roulante un petit espace qui pousse au
dialogue et aux conseils pour le choix
des adhérents immédiate est comme ça à
mobile à proximité tout le monde
moi je trouve l'idée géniale franchement
c'est bien moi mes enfants ont passé
comme ça par hasard et ils sont contents
je trouve que c'est très bien parce
qu'on n'a plus rien et ça va nous
changer pour venir chercher des livres
moi je suis ravi pratique pour les
personnes âgées attirant pour les
enfants le bibliobus
un concept qui marche ou plutôt qui
roule et ne recevront à présent sur ce
gâteau notre journaliste sportif à
michael elle me d'euros pour la
traditionnelle chronique sport j'ai dit
bon je suis ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
handball féminin l'équipe senior de
monty bretenoux qui évolue en nationale
une 2 sera plus entraînée par philippe
l'étrange le coach qui a pris en main
l'équipe en 2013 s'occupe désormais des
jeunes pour nous parler de ce coup de
théâtre nous recevrons sur ce plateau
justement l'ex entraîneur de l'équipe
philippe l'étrange bonsoir alors nous
allons tout est rentré dans le vif du
sujet pourquoi avez vous quitté vos
fonctions je crois que maintenant y
avait trop de filles qui étaient plus à
mon écoute et donc c'est ça devenait
très compliqué pour elle et pour moi
donc j'ai pris une décision peut-être
difficile à prendre
il fallait je crois la prendre pour
essayer de sauver l'équipe en nationale
1 il y avait des tensions entre les deux
et ça faisait un moment que ça dure est
peut-être une petite année donc c'était
ça devenait compliqué donc fallu fallait
faire ce choix peut-être difficile parce
que c'est un travail inachevé ma part
mais bon en espérant que l'équipe arrive
à se maintenir avec les nouvelles
personnes qui vont encadrer et vous
pensez que votre message ne passait plus
oui oui je pense qu'il passait plus
est-ce qu'il est passé je sais pas moi
je me pose moins de cette question là
maintenant c'est sûr qu'ils passaient
plus à la fin et c'était difficile dans
et d'entraîner et de manager lors des
matchs donc il fallait fallait faire ce
je crois qu'elles étaient les
difficultés justement plus aller coûte
voilà je sais pour la fois à leur
demande et je pense mais c'était
compliqué très compliqué c'était
finalement à divorce inéluctable ouais
je crois quoi qu'il arrive
voilà france les ja déjà l'année
dernière
juste après le match de barrage qu'on
avait remporté donc avec l'accession en
nationale 1 il ya des filles qui sont
allées au bureau pour moi demandé ma
tête donc c'était un peu compliqué quoi
donc moi j'ai pensé qu'avec la montée
saleh se disparaître pour qu'on
travaille tous en essence pour essayer
et puis peut-être qu'elles étaient plus
motivés pour avoir de nouveau ma tête
que de 2 sur un terrain je sais pas on
sait quoi et comment gères justement les
ce groupe quand on sait que voilà vous
n'étiez peut être plus le bienvenu chez
chez certaines choses dans un premier
temps on ferme les yeux et puis on reste
concentré sur les entraînements et sur
les matches qui arrivent toutes les
semaines
et puis petit à petit ça pour un petit
peu aussi l'ambiance la préparation des
entraînements dehors les déplacements
souvent il y avait donc c'était ça
devenait très compliqué et vous
regretter certains passages peut-être
certains moments dans votre management
non je regrette rien c'est moi qui ai
choisi cette équipe là même bien mais
avec les difficultés le peut-être le
regret c'est de ne pas avoir su
peut-être virer les filles qui
séparés des filles qui étaient qui était
plus du tout aller coûte bon mais c'est
tout moi je n'ai pas fait donc je
regrette rien maintenant gp ces
décisions là pour aussi de sauver
montigny et vous allez remplacer des
loups normalement je suis remplacé la
des swing et le week-end qui arrive
l'attend le club de montigny a pas
encore communiqué vous avez un an je
crois oui j'ai bruno philippe qui vient
du sud et continuera à vous suivre à
philippe l'étrange crois que vous allez
vous équiper des jeunes désormais là
j'étais venu pour les jeunes donc j'ai
fait une pige avec les seniors et puis
moi je retourne chez les jeunes
l'assignation
merci où il est passé sur ce plateau bon
courage pour la suite de l'affairé à
présent rendez vous sportif il y aura
notamment de la gymnastique une
compétition très importante florane le
championnat régional de gymnastique est
programmée ce week-end au palais des
sports d'el en cours les meilleurs
sportifs d'île de france sont présents
pour ce rendez vous les favoris sont une
nouvelle fois les athlètes du club du
club de gymnastique d'elancourt maurepas
avec marlène mike a été vice championne
de france en 2015 et zélie leriche
jeunes gymnastes de 10 ans qui a été
championne de france l'année dernière
si vous voulez assister à l'événement la
compétition est gratuite c'est enfin à
présent le grand écart pour prendre la
direction de menton le bretonneux l'aise
ou mon temps je ressens jauron se
rencontrent ce temps le match aura
peut-être décisif dans la course à la
montée monte inique et occupe
actuellement la troisième place du
classement du championnat de première
c'est la fonte le quatrième stage ce
dimanche à 15 heures un choc qui
s'annonce s'annonce donc décisif lésigny
montain pointe actuellement à 13 points
de la première place mais en rugby on ne
sait jamais et mon tir aient sur deux
victoires consécutives et notamment un
sang neuf à 0 contre pantin les saint
quentinois sont donc en forme
vous allez suivre ce match floral mais
pourquoi pas vous connaissez ma passion
pour le ballon ovale on vous retrouve
demain michael pour le 7-8 week-end quel
programme
alors nous parlerons de la réouverture
du zoo de thoiry avec le comte paul de
la panouse mais aussi l'absence vantant
votre fête préférée floral
si vous n'avez rien de prévu je vous
proposerai quelques idées de sorties est
un peu présomptueux mais calme et si je
vais au rugby je ne vais pas pouvoir
tout faire mais j'écouterai vos idées
avec attention merci beaucoup
et justement la saint valentin la fête
des amoureux approche c'est dimanche la
date fatidique dans les yvelines des
dizaines de rendez vous romantiques sont
programmées pour ce 14 février la bd vos
de cerner le parc zoologique de thoiry
propose des événements insolites sur
mesure pour les coudes pour les couples
pardon justement michael l
oh et patrick jacques de dixmude vous en
dit un peu plus pour la saint valentin
les établissements des civils ont entamé
une opération à séduction dans l'abbaye
des vaux de cerner la direction joue la
carte historique de repas sont organisés
les 13 et 14 février dans l'ancienne
demeure sister scène datant du xiième
siècle les couples pour ensuite passer
la nuit dans l'une des cinquante sept
chambres de l'établissement
une recette qui fonctionne depuis dix
ans on a des clients qui reviennent tous
les ans pour fêter la saint-valentin ici
on a même des clients qui viennent à
deux couples une table 2,4 pour fêter la
saint valentin sont originales mais ça
arrive donc c'est une soirée qui plaît
pas mal et sur laquelle on a de la
demande donc c'est pour ça qu'on réitère
tous les ans au niveau du menu
l'établissement a créé de nouveaux plats
pour ce rendez vous place à sera une
saint jacques avec une gambas oxydes au
son du cor base de nouvelle calédonie
accompagné d'une c6 n'a c'est un jambon
de boeuf en fait qui est séché fumée et
une mousseline de céleri un sabayon
citronnée c'est un plaque et pas trop
puissant en goût et qui reste à faire
les produits naturels et seydou et ça
plaît à tout le monde à thoiry le pack
joue également les cupidons pour la
cinquième année consécutive un dîner
romantique à 225 euros est organisé le
dimanche soir dans les salons
historiques du château 20 tables sont
dressées pour l'occasion un château des
feux de cheminée une ambiance tamisée
une harpiste
quelque chose de très intime de bons
repas devant un bon feu de cheminée dans
un cadre historique je crois que ça
donne envie
cette année sept couples sur dix
fêteront la saint valentin en france et
pour les célibataires ou les allergiques
à la fête de l'amour vous pouvez
toujours passer un bon dimanche au coin
du feu et pour un budget à moins onéreux
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
nous avoir suivis demain vous avez
rendez vous avec wilfrid errishi pour
l'essentiel de l'actu compte à moi je
vous retrouve lundi pour le journal je
vous souhaite donc une très bonne soirée
et un excellent week-end